[Music]
all right so if you've been watching our
basic how-to Aikido a series you
understand now the the basic kind of
distancing we're trying to work with an
Aikido that the goal in Aikido is never
to get the other person just to put them
in a very difficult position to get me
and then that it's possible if that
distance breaks down and what are we
going to do when that distance breaks
down now the second the distance breaks
down I want to bury the line we call
that tie no pinko a position change and
I also want to get some kind of
suppression suppression is keeping his
hands from being able to really easily
get to me
so if Josh was coming in to shove me I
want to get some kind of suppression on
his arms now if I'm real strong and
maybe I could shove them away with this
that would be great but that's not the
main goal of this the main goal of this
is to get his arm under some kind of
control when you're trying to suppress
the arm the best place to be is right
around the elbow so I'm at the hand his
hand moves too fast it's hard for me to
keep track of if I'm at his shoulder the
shoulder moves very slow but it's easy
for him to move his armor and a lot of
mobility to move his arm around if I
hold it at the elbow his elbow moves
slow enough that I can usually track it
and I can control almost all the motion
of the arm so it's very hard for him to
grab me or do anything to me cut me so
elbow controls what we ideally want in
Aikido we call this Iko Iko is the first
principle lesson of Aikido now
ego is not armed barring someone so a
lot of people think it was some kind of
pushing of the elbow to break it or
something like that has nothing to do
with iko iko is simply elbow control now
the greatest Ethio I can have would me
being on the underside of the eto and
that gives me a lot of control over his
body and it's a really good technique
because it resets the distance meaning
once I'm under here and he's unbalanced
I can shove him off of me and I reset
the distance remember a knife you know
all I want to do is be at that
conversational distance that's always
what I'm trying to do so Ethio could
shove them away that's ideal beyond that
even if I
can't show more with the e key oh I want
to be able to control his arm ideally at
the elbow so he can't grab me easily you
can't stab me get me cut me anything
like that now this e Keo might lead us
into lots of other stuff for example if
we were here and I needed to disarm them
I could come underneath to get the Nico
I could also disarm him with a Sankyo if
I'm having trouble with my eto I can use
a young feel to want to make him want to
bring his elbow back up if his arm
completely collapsed in I can set up a
gokyo with that if from here's arm shot
straight I'm having trouble with it I
can set up a variety of rocio's in there
right so these IPO techniques come not
because I want to twist his wrist or I
want to shove him somewhere they happen
because he's broken down the distance I
couldn't keep the distance I want and
now that we're in here I'm presented
with a dangerous situation and I need to
control it suppress his arm in some kind
of way so he can't grab me or if he had
a weapon caught me or hurt me with the
weapon so this eco is our basic line of
connection to him when were in distance
now I would always like to get out to
distance so if I can move him away or
move myself for example with Akio Oda I
could move myself around the back side
of him that would be ideal for me and
what I would really like to do so
understand I feel techniques are not
coming up because that's the way I'm
gonna get him I don't want to get him
that's not my goal what the why they're
coming up is because he's provided a
situation that's so difficult for me to
answer that I need to use these
techniques all of the Aikido techniques
work in exactly this way and they work
on putting me in a good position and him
in a bad position very consistently so
this is a rough idea of why these
techniques would arise in Aikido next
we're going to talk about the kill Wazza
versus the Naga Wazza